Reporting live for Channel 12 News, where
some truly bizarre shit is going down.
If I can activate the reptilians
themselves in this newly hatched snake,
the particulate growth would be nearly unlimited.
It works! It works!
Welcome to Compton, California.
In order to work these streets,
you gotta be these streets.
You gotta taste these streets.
You gotta know what the deal is as a seller.
No, I'm gonna do it.
I'm lactose intolerant, man.
You think the dealers care if you're lactose-intolerant?
You think I care about you kids and your
crunk dubstep people believable bullshit?
We got the biggest gig of our lives tomorrow.
I got you all into Upper Case Records.
We get signed. We be ballin'.
Yeah!
I can hear your lame-ass beats a mile away.
I thought I recognised the sound of your AK-47.
You better have my money!
My snake! Has anyone seen my snake?
A mutated snake?
What the fuck?
My invention supercharged it
with them stable molecules.
Now it's growing at an uncontrolled rate.
Holy Mary J. Blige.
What you're saying is, it's big
enough to eat this Twinkie?
It's not a big Twinkie.
My ding dong is bigger than that.
There is a snake terrorising Compton!
You gotta help me capture it, so I can run more tests.
We catch this snake, and I'll be famous.
We talking about the cover of Time magazine.
Maybe even YouTube.
I'm so done with this snake!
You know I hate snakes!
If you are such a goddamn artist, why
don't you bust a rhyme right now?
You standing right here in this very
spot in this strip club steppin' at me?
Any moron can bust a rhyme, right?
Stick your shrimpy little girl hands down
the drain and just pull the snake out.
Oh god!
I lost my watch!